Speaker 1: Let's go next to Hunter from
Colorado. Hunter, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, how you
doing? I'm doing well, thank you.
So I wanted to ask, what do you
think in light of the news that
William Shatner and all these guys are
wanting to go to space, do you think?
But that's actually important at all, or
do you think it's just a pissing contest,
do you think they're doing it for the
good of humanity or just themselves?
Speaker 1: I think I think it's both. I think
it doesn't really matter why they are doing it.
I am confident that the things we will learn
from developing space exploration technology will
benefit humanity. Now, whether that's
why Jeff Bezos is doing it and Elon Musk,
or really it's just kind of, you know,
just a competition among rich, rich people
is up for debate could be a little bit of
both. But I think that it's still going to
benefit us in terms of technological development.
But in terms of like, is it important that William
Shatner personally, you know, go up on the
second launch? Not really. I mean, you know,
I guess you could say there's more attention
paid to it when prominent people are involved,
but I don't really think it matters if William
Shatner goes up. I mean, the tough thing about
this is all of this stuff is a combination. It's
a combination of rich dudes wanting attention.
Fascinating technological development. What rich
people do when they're not sure how to spend their
money, it's all of the above. And so you can't
divorce any of this stuff from the fact that,
hey, you know, maybe if some of these corporations
and rich people really paid the taxes that are
their fair share, maybe they wouldn't have as much
money to do all this stuff. But but they probably
still would have enough. They wouldn't have as
much, but they'd probably still have enough.
And it would be the right thing to do morally
in terms of making people pay their fair share.
But that doesn't mean it's a bad
thing that this is what they're doing.
A lot of people just want to be very black
and white, like, is this good or is it bad?
Very few things are so simple in life.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yeah, I'm totally in agreement,
I think it brings a lot of attention to
space travel and the importance of it,
but at the end of the day, I think they're kind of
mainly doing it to benefit themselves and kind of
get investors to throw more money at them.
Speaker 1: So I mean, listen in a very,
you know, to take a very kind of dark approach
to it. Eventually, Earth will not be habitable
anymore. Right, the sun is going to expand
and consume the Earth, so at a certain point,
if humanity wants to continue, we're going to
have to be able to go somewhere else. And so
if the first people to start pushing us in
that direction are some of the early people
do it because they want fame or money. OK. I mean,
that's why they do it. But at a certain point,
it's something humanity would need to do.
Speaker 3: I agree. Let's get there.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you
very much, appreciate the call.
An important topic for sure. Let's go next to
Steph from Wisconsin. Steph, you are on the air.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, thanks for taking the
call. Pleasure. I have two questions. OK,
so the first one is I don't know if
you've seen the new data from the FDA,
but they claim about the Moderna's booster and I
know that you've got more data. So I was wondering
if you were planning on getting the booster.
Speaker 1: So Steph, if I if I read the I only
glanced at an article, but correct me if I'm
wrong. What they said is they are not really
taking a position as to whether Maddern recipients
should get a third shot, that two shots remain
effective against serious illness and death.
But it's sort of up to the individual to decide.
Exactly. Yeah, yeah. I haven't made a
decision to be honest about a third shot yet.
OK. Yeah, I don't know, I mean, it's
I I'd gladly go and get one. You know,
I don't have any problem with getting a
third shot. I felt pretty lousy after both
my first and second shots, I would go and
get one. It's just not yet clear to me that
I should be the next person doing it.
I don't know. I really don't know.
Speaker 6: Yeah. The tough stuff into the side.
And so the second one kind of in the same vein,
I have you seen the data suggesting that the
flu shot boosts the COVID vaccine efficacy.
And would you consider doing a segment on it?
Speaker 1: I have not seen that,
and I absolutely would consider doing a
segment on it if you can. If you can email
some of that data to info at David Pakman dot
com that so the argument is you get a flu shot
and it makes the COVID vaccine more efficacious.
Speaker 6: Right. I don't want to misstate it
because I haven't done like a deep dove into
it. And so that's what I was just curious
about. That's what how I understood it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I'm finding articles.
I'm finding studies which say flu shot linked
to less severe COVID 19. But we have, you know,
there's a big correlation causation thing we have
to look more about. You're not wrong that there
are such reports. I'd want to look into the more.
Speaker 6: OK. OK, awesome. I will definitely
send those to the email.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks,
Steph. Appreciate it. Yeah, thank you. All
right, Steph from Wisconsin coming in with some
meaty topics. Let's take a quick break.
We're going to keep taking calls,
so don't go anywhere. Don't hang up.
If you're holding on to talk to me,
we're just going to take a very, very quick
break and then go right back to the phones